if watching the queen's gambit has you
looking to make your next moving content
you're in luck because we have five
picks that are sure to be a checkmate on
this week's bench guide
the first season of the queen's gambit
has fans and critics swooning over its
stylized storytelling and compelling
characters that feel
so real yet stunningly are all works of
fiction so if you can't decide what move
to make next we have put together five
titles that we think are part of a
winning binge strategy
starting with our actor spotlight emma
queen's gambit star anya taylor joy
stars in his british
period comedy drama adaptation of the
jane austen novel of the same name
as emma woodhouse a young woman in 19th
century england whose antics and
matching are
simply delightful fans of taylor joy
will love
seeing her show off her lighter side
after darker rolls like in the witch or
split
and while it might not stick to the
exact tone critics say jane austen fans
should still find a solid match in emma
and have praised it for its modern
approach
energy and unique adaptation emma has a
total run time of two hours and five
minutes which is basically a nice
healthy break between your marathon
chess session
next up is our throwback pick and that's
going to mad men which debuted back in
2007.
this drama is about a high-profile ad
agency in new york in the 1960s it's
enigmatic exact on draper and tons of
drinking
jon hamm picked up two golden globes and
an emmy for his breakout performance
playing said drinking executive draper
across seven certified fresh seasons but
it's the 60s ambiance brilliantly
crafted characters and razor sharp
writing that will have queens fans
feeling especially at home
it'll take you about 79 hours to binge
the whole series which is just enough
time to master
all the cocktails while soaking in all
that great mid-century design
everything just seemed so much cooler
back then moving on to our brand new
pick this week and it's going to
the great starring elle fanning and
nicholas holt this genre-bending comedy
drama follows catherine the great on her
rise to power in 18th century russia now
the show features delicious performances
and a wicked sense of humor
and it was just renewed for a second
season so there's even more greatness on
the way which is great for us
and with just 10 episodes at just under
an hour each you can binge this one in
roughly eight and a half
hours and for our certified fresh pick
this week we are jumping all the way
back to the 50s to the marvelous mrs
maisel
rachel brosnahan stars as miriam midge
maisel a housewife whose blissful life
is uprooted after she discovers her true
calling
stand-up comedy this award-winning
amazon prime series from gilmore girls
creator amy sherman palladino has been
recognized for its ability to deliver
warmth
empowerment and a whole lot of laughs
and its ensemble cast of characters
offers something for everyone you can
binge
all three seasons in just under 25 hours
and nobody will blame you if you pick up
some new jokes along the way
and finally our family-friendly pick
this week is going to queen of katwe
this certified fresh feel-good chest
drama snuck into theaters in 2016
and with queen's gambit reigniting
interest in checkerboard action we think
that it's worth revisiting
oscar winner lupita nyong'o and david
oyelowo
star in this biographical drama about
finoa mutesi
a struggling slum-bound eugandian girl
who learns to play chess and uses the
game and her exceptional skill to propel
herself
all the way to the world chess olympiad
featuring uncommon smarts and
outstanding performances and with a
total run time of just an hour and 24
minutes
this was a no brainer for people looking
for a great film on the shorter side or
a family-friendly alternative to the
more adult themes on queen's
gambit all right friends so hopefully
this will have you saying checkmate on
your next few bench sessions
be sure to let us know what you're
currently streaming in the comments and
also if you don't want to miss out on
any future recommendations based around
the movies and shows that you love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always
we can't thank you enough for watching
binge guide and we'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
you